jolie com el ozono se recuperó de su
derrota el que llegó tercero a la
primera vuelta de la elección
presidencial pidió a los franceses de
ayudarle a convertirse en el primer
ministro del nuevo presidente
los
de jose donde he venido esta noche para
decirles una cosa pidió al pueblo
francés que me elija primer ministro les
pido que me elijan primer ministro
eligiendo una mayoría de diputados
insumisos y de la unión popular y llamó
a todos los que quieran unirse a la
unión popular es decir a la esencia de
su programa a unirse a nosotros para
esta gran batalla es un juego
adam newton set de batalla los franceses
no eligen el primer ministro es el nuevo
presidente el que lo designada sin
embargo todo se podría jugar en la
elección legislativa de junio en la cual
los ciudadanos serán llamados a elegir a
los 577 diputados de la asamblea
nacional la cámara baja del poder
legislativo si los partidos de izquierda
logran una mayoría en esta elección la
transición estipula que el presidente
elija un primer ministro del campo de
esta nueva mayoría
una cohabitación meloso siempre para
entonces para lo que llamo la tercera
vuelta de la elección y esta vez no
quiere dejar escapar su oportunidad
silvio así que lo digo si queremos
podemos y esta vez no es una pequeña
oportunidad hay una puerta que está ahí
o la tomas o eligen la otra el actual
primer ministro yo castex ya anunció su
intención de presentar la dimisión
rápida de su gobierno si mcu es
reelegido
si el presidente de la república es
reelegido la costumbre es que en los
días siguientes el primer ministro
presente la dimisión de su gobierno y
como soy profundamente republicano
cumpliré con esta costumbre republicano
de hacer una tradición que son castex
justifica por la necesidad de dar un
nuevo impulso al país antes de las
legislativas